All right. We already knew that lines B and
D should be in the final list, since they were in both files.
Before, we didn't really know whether the lines had been there at the beginning
of the day or whether Jake and Rachel had both added them.
But now we know, it was already there.
Now let's look at A.
At the beginning of the day, line A was present.
Rachel's file still contains it, so she didn't do anything with it.
But Jake's file doesn't contain it.
That means that he removed line A.
So we don't want it in the final file.
Now let's look at C.
C doesn't appear in the original and Jake doesn't have it either, but
Rachel does.
Since it wasn't there to begin with,
we know that she added it, so it should be in the file.
The same thing goes for E.
Since it's not in the original, but Jake has it,
we do want it in the final file.